hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at the final game of the 2019 sync field
cup
this was a Blitz game between Magnus
Carlson on the white end and dingler in
these are the two who were tied after
the regular event
11 games of classical
they each had six and a half points
they were forced to play a tie break
faster games
two rapid games were played those were
draws next up a Blitz game and dingler
in one the first Blitz game and here is
Blitz game number two Carlson now finds
himself in a must-win situation
okay I'm drawing some attention to this
because it plays a role in Carlson's
decisions in this game
playing what's best in the computer's
eyes is not going to be best
in many cases in this one
so he has to go all in a draw is not
going to be helpful on board we have a
closed Roy Lopez typical play on The
Queen side black going after the light
Square Bishop some tension in the center
somewhat released
there will be no pin on the Knight
rookie eight
moments away black is from making the
capture and then having this coordinated
pressure on e4 white says not so fast
so centers close this last move now
looks somewhat Ridiculous by black
is it really a big deal that The Rook
will now have to make another move
before it's productive because there's
no excitement happening on the e-file it
is closed
it's not really a big deal
centers closed
closed positions not really so much a
factor this time element there will be
time to maneuver the pieces
some clarification something is still
gained with this move there is some
clarification with the structure we kind
of have a better idea where the position
or where the pieces should be positioned
centers locked play must ensue on the
wings
normally where you have space that's the
side of the board you should be looking
to play and with this last move white
has space we can say
on the queen side
one of the squares that sticks out to me
about this position is C6
this is a reason to in general try and
play on the same side of the board where
you have space there's a good chance you
could maybe
coordinate with that furthest Advanced
Pawn of yours
so we could maybe see if white plays on
The Queen side in this position maybe
there's a chance one of the white pieces
can arrive on C6 and be a great bother
to the black side
as it turns out in this game and in this
specific structure it will actually be
black who plays on The Queen side of the
board where black is lacking space
whereas white will be playing on the
king's side he's really going to go
after try to at least go after the black
King's throat
okay
Where Do We Begin Bishop D7
important not to say to yourself I have
A6 and b5n let's feed Keto
this would be bad for two reasons one
you're biting on a rock
and two you just got in the way of your
knight it may want to Pivot on B7
quickly
okay in this game it's Bishop D7
has an eye on one day maybe getting to
the B5 Square
okay from here Knight C3
Queen B8
there's two thoughts that crossed my
mind when I see Queen b81
getting out of the way of The Rook so it
could get to this only open file
then two you're getting out of The
Bishop's way
you may want to Pivot on d8 and then go
to B6
keep in mind it's this dark Square
Bishop that is the bad Bishop for black
okay from here Bishop D3 watches out
watches out over this C4 Square
if white simply continues to develop
with Bishop E3 that's your this would be
irritating hitting the bishop in Pawn
you probably have to undo your move
okay so Bishop D3 watches over the night
move and also in general a good idea
probably to get the minor pieces off of
this only open file otherwise they're
going to eventually feel some pressure
by the major pieces
okay Rook C8 follows
Knight E2
Knight B7 and here we go
on this move 17 G4 G4 Knight G3 right
around the corner
now I have a pop quiz for you
let's say G4 is not played here and
instead white continues to develop this
is considered one of the other
top moves in this position for white
so let's say this is in here and then
black inserts this move H6 a flight
Square
seems like a healthy move
what is your assessment of this position
what is the best move here for white
so feel free to try and answer maybe one
of those two questions maybe both if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what you come up with
okay
this is actually a winning position for
white although I can't give you a
specific variation that says aha that's
why White's winning
why is white winning in this position
um
what is the best move for white in this
position it's B4
and
this traps this night
so it's not trapped in the sense aha
okay you don't have any great moves and
soon I'm going to win the night
it's more like now this feeling keto
Knight simply it will exist in the game
but not really live
it's completely dominated by Pawns
so right now the bee Pawn is killing it
and if you try to go to the only other
Square you have access to
this guy starts to laugh at you
so wherever you go one of these two
Pawns
is killing the Knight so how else do you
activate this guy you have to bend over
backwards you have to move this this
Knight this Pawn there's weaknesses
there when you do that
just to get to this Square it's a it's a
struggling piece
so
this is an important detail
G4 in this game I should mention
first of all I should mention that
in this position right here
when B4 is played Black doesn't have a
way to undermine this Pawn
A5 white says no problem I could
maintain this point
Chop Chop this Rook is defended
no problems Pawn is maintained here your
knight is dead
still
black is playing down a piece okay in
our game we have G4
and then the Knight goes to C5 so you
may be asking here
why doesn't white play B4 it's not the
same because this Rook is not defended
and this point in other words could be
undermined successfully in this position
A5 could in other words no longer be met
with A3
chop you cannot recapture you would lose
the Rook
so there's no controlling this Knight
there was a reason I earlier threw in
that term quickly when I said the night
may want to make use of B7 quickly it's
important that he is able to get to this
Square before he's boxed out with the B4
advance
okay in this game G4 follows
Knight C5 straight away
pressure on both bishop and Pawn
E4 is defended
black takes out the light Square Bishop
now this is the first moment black is on
move has that unopposed bishop and
immediately looks to put it to use
B4 with great effect
a skewer looking to win some material
okay black is or white is out of that
with rookie one
Queen B5
white needs to try and keep the Queens
on to keep open winning chances Ducks
the queen Exchange
and now black from here looking to
double the Rooks
has that this guy's trying to offset the
Rooks in a way
we'll see what the idea is here some
controlling moves with G6 no forward
Night Moves
B3 here we go the Knight is ready to
interfere with both Rooks
Knight on C4
black is ready to knock out the Knight
though he's anticipating Knight C4
Knight C4 look at how quickly
its challenge Bishop B5 Knight A5 so
initially I was saying white is playing
on the king side of the board but we do
have some play here now some moves later
white is interacting with this for this
Advanced Pawn some coordination here on
C6
from here Queen B8
Queen D2
there's pressure on B4
Rook C3
white tries to undermine The Rook
support with A3 Pawn takes pawn and now
we have this interference move so black
had to see this coming
it's going to be losing some material
here losing the exchange
takes the Knight
Queen takes Rook Bishop takes Pawn so
this guy is still an unopposed Bishop
we have a past Pawn as well
on A3
Bishop takes E4
G5 so this is this had to be calculated
right here this decision believe Carlson
by surprise this bishop takes E4
what is the idea that black has here
after Bishop takes E4 G5 if you simply
move the Knight
you're going to lose the bishop so
Can you spot what Black's next move is
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video
what does he come up with here
okay here we go
Bishop A8
unopposed Bishop
this bishop has knocked out both White
Center pawns and next up
there is this idea to form a battery
and go in for mate
so
objectively best in this position is to
go ahead and take the Knight but there
would now be no better than a draw
so
in this game what's played as Queen
takes Pawn
if you take the Knight what is this draw
exactly Queen B7 this King has to take a
hike
black would go in for check and
basically this is the best both sides
can do from here if you're going here
it's considered to be a win for black
after Bishop here
and the King ends up getting stuck in
the center
some ideas of check Rook entering stuff
best in this position is some repetition
of position
so
white has to try for something more
and he captures on A6 in this case
now comes Knight D5
Bishop A7
Queen C7 Rook e to C1
and we have black give up the queen for
the two Rooks this isn't considered best
turns out to be very nice the
the queen for two Rooks in balance
black ends up working very well
uh coordinating very well with the light
Square Bishop
considered best in this position is to
go into a pin that's that's really
especially for a Blitz game to pull a
move off like that
you would have to foresee that after
this
and then
some move like Queen D7 in here you have
a pawn advance that distracts the major
pieces from observing C6
and also C8
okay doesn't go into a pin gives up the
queen for both Rooks
check on board nearby there could be a
mate and this night is there defending
we could start to see this coordination
on that H1 Square now
from here Bishop C6
from here Queen takes A3 considered
better is A3
still around an even position keeps the
bishop out from
getting on this diagonal really taking
the pawn and then getting to F4
putting the bishop on
a diagonal right next to the light
Square Bishop
okay in this game is Queen takes A3 on
The Rook
Bishop takes G5 and after White's next
move it's going to be a win for black
there's only one saving move here for
white
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you could spot what's
considered the best move for white
okay
in this game Queen takes D6 is played
best move
is considered Knight E2
not just about hitting the Rook but it's
there to stop the Bishop from getting to
F4
it's ready to immediately take the
bishop out if it goes there
and we'll as we'll see the bishop on F4
is really crushing and really
coordinates well with the other lights
with the other Bishop
so in this game is Queen takes D6
Bishop F4
had to be played knowing that there's a
good reply to White's move here Bishop
C5 and we reach this final moment of the
game there's only one more move
if black doesn't spot this next move if
he hadn't calculated this next move it
would actually be white who's winning
so final Pop Quiz Can you spot this
beautiful final move
by black feel free to pause the video
okay here it is
97.
so there was a there was a mate threat
here by White Queen Effie
Knight E7 stops the maintenance one
threat and at the same time threatens a
major one
this night on G3 is pinned
this is a beautiful finish
uh to this 2000 what was the 2019
sinkfield cup
white simply throws in the towel there's
nothing you can really do
about this mate thread on H1 you have to
basically throw away all of your pieces
to stop me
so what's considered one of the better
lines here this is considered best to
give up the queen that's going to go
nowhere
of course
if you try to play F3 and then interfere
with this Rook getting to H1 that's not
going to be helpful
Knight F5 and this Knight is going to
fall
uh what do you do about that you can
throw in a check King G7
this is a main threat
and if you move the bishop you're
getting mated on H1 so white isn't a
giant pickle if you try H4 there goes
the one piece there goes another and
right around the corner we have made on
H1 at the end of the day so
really a beautiful finish I would say to
this uh 2019 sync field cup to see that
you have that move after Bishop F4 you
have a great way to respond to Bishop C5
Knight E7 very very nice finish to this
one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
foreign